welcome to planet earth she's got the
toughest streets around and if you're
not careful that mean old missy won't
hesitate to wash out her gutters with
your blood and decorate the sidewalks
with your teeth it's a tough world for
the good and innocent with the looming
shadow of crime lurking around every
corner just waiting to prey on those who
are unable to defend themselves if you
don't have the tools to survive it'll
chew you up and spit you out like a wad
of stale chewing gum that's why we need
a hero a dark defender a cloak in the
night we need the specter
new delhi india
a woman walks home from her late night
job she's exhausted she can feel the
bone deep ache of 14 hours on a factory
line running herself ragged to support
her three kids back home she can barely
stand can you really blame her for
wanting to take the shortcut down that
dark alley knowing it'll shave 15
minutes off her trip she ducks in
clutching her purse tight and keeping
her head down but it won't do any good a
predator has been lying in weight he
emerges from the darkness wielding a
huge knife and grabs her by the shoulder
he's a few heads taller than her with
arms thicker than her neck he tells her
to hand over the money she'd spend all
month working for or he'd turn her kids
into orphans his knife had tasted blood
before and he'd have no problem killing
again with tears streaking down her face
knowing it's futile to resist she
reaches out and passes him the money the
bandit snatches it from her trembling
hand and snickers candy from a baby he's
ready to turn around and make a run with
tonight's takings when he feels an odd
chill drift into the alley a soft whoosh
he turns and sees a figure standing and
watching him he's tall and well built
with a long black coat and a wide
brimmed hat he was darker than the dark
light seemed to disappear into him a
black shape against the background it's
him the man that all criminals know and
fear
all over the world even if they've never
met him the intrusive thought the moment
of creeping doubt that slithers into
their minds the second they even
contemplate breaking the law the bad
guys boogie man
the specter
halt evildoer the specter commands
you'll return this fine lady's money or
you'll suffer the consequences the
bandit feels the tremor of fear quiver
through him but he won't back down
not yet he charges the spectre with this
blade slashing like a madman but not a
single hit lands the specter weaves
perfectly away from every strike and
effortlessly disarms the bandit with a
perfectly placed whack to the wrist the
knife clatters to the ground he
discombobulates the bandit with an open
palm strike to either side of his head
then knocks him out with a laser-focused
headbutt he crumples to the ground
unconscious and the spectre breathes a
sigh another battle won this whole time
the woman has been watching frozen in
awe the spectre picks up her stolen
money and hands it back to her with a
gentleman lead off of his wide-brimmed
hat he really is just darkness
underneath unseeable unknowable a living
shadow
she thanks him and he assures her that
it's all in a day's work for a crime
fighter like him after all somebody
needs to do it and in a flash of smoke
he's gone the woman makes it home safely
that night london england a man lays
beaten and bloody on the ground three
assailants surround him circling like
hungry wolves one wields a long lead
pipe still slick with the man's blood
another a switchblade that he keeps
clicking in and out of the handle and
the third carries a handgun the same
handgun he's used to take two lives
before the wounded man on the ground
with bruises cuts a broken ankle a
broken wrist four broken ribs and three
missing teeth is desperate and afraid
he's here because he was forced into a
corner he needed to borrow money from a
dangerous man tucked away in a dingy
building in london's east end the city's
organized crime epicenter the money he'd
borrow came with predatory interest that
he couldn't pay back now he's paying the
difference in blood to that same loan
shark's violent goons the man with a gun
in a thick cockney accent tells him that
this is why he shouldn't have messed
around with mr ford now he's going to be
an example for anyone else stupid enough
to think they can stiff the big man on a
payment and live to tell the tale he
nods to the man with the pipe to finish
the job the beaten and bloodied man on
the ground closes his eyes as the goon
steps closer lifting up the red stained
pipe and preparing to finally cave his
pitiful head in with it in the dark he
hears the whoosh of the pipes downswing
and the breeze hits his bruised cheek
but the pipe never connects instead
there's a chorus of gasps the man on the
ground opens his eyes to get a better
look at what on earth has happened a
tall dark man in a long black coat and a
wide brimmed hat is standing over him
holding the lead pipe that he'd just
easily snatch from the hands of its
previous user the goons are all stepping
back the gunman raises his pistol the
other his knife all of them look afraid
the man on the ground doesn't know the
stranger who just saved his life but in
his presence he feels something wash
over him that he hasn't felt in a long
while
safety it's him it's the spectre you
wretched villains do you know better
than to pick on the weak a bunch of
tough guys like you how about fighting
someone your own size in a blind panic
the gunman raises his pistol and fires
the specter moves like smoke in the wind
he dodges the bullet and tosses the lead
pipe it sails through the air and hits
the gunman's skull with an almighty
crack he collapses dropping his weapon
the other two goons bum-rush him but it
doesn't serve them any better one
slashes the other punches with a few
skillful fluid movements he guides one
goon's knife-wielding hand into the
other shoulder then disables both with a
pair of simultaneous chops to the throat
like that jackie chan himself would be
proud of all three goons are laid out on
the ground either writhing and gasping
or knocked out cold the spectre
straightens his coat and hat with
practice finesse and returns to the man
laying on the ground after checking that
he was still alive and conscious he
passed the man a wad of cash and a phone
telling him to call an ambulance and get
his wounds treated none of those men
would ever bother him again and if they
or any others dared to then they could
expect to see the dark figure of the
spectre appearing behind them in their
bathroom mirror after all someone needs
to be there to fight crime even when
nobody else will new york city usa
things are going sideways at a major
bank downtown a group of well-armed
highly organized robbers has broken in
they've taken at least 50 hostages
throughout the building and have
informed the police blockade outside
that unless their demands are met and
they're given free passage out of the
building they'll start executing people
left and right and given the ruthless
organization of this particular criminal
crew it seems more than likely that
they'll put their blood money where
their mouth is police squad cars form a
horseshoe blockade around the building
outside armed with handguns shotguns and
assault rifles police snipers are
finding their ideal perches in the
surrounding skyscrapers swat is on the
way and a police helicopter circles
above however even if everything goes
right the higher-ups know that some
fatalities are basically inevitable
crews of hardcore career criminals like
this wouldn't go down without a fight
one way or another some lives would be
taken today another transmission is
delivered from the inside after that the
robbers know that time isn't on their
side so they're flipping the script five
minutes exactly if their demands aren't
met by then blood would be staining the
bank's immaculate marble floor tick tock
the negotiators on the front line are in
a cold sweat five minutes no that isn't
enough time we can't mobilize there'll
be a massacre in there how could 10
greedy maniacs with assault rifles pull
the rug out from under them all like
this panicked thoughts swim through the
head of a sergeant heading the blockade
he can't concede his superiors would
never allow it does he wait five minutes
and see what happens or authorize his
officers to breach the front doors try
to reclaim the bank and potentially
create one of the worst bank robbery
bloodbaths in new york city history
damned if he does
damned if he doesn't and every second
the time to decide runs out that's when
he hears a soft whoosh behind him
paranoid enough to jump at shadows the
sergeant turns reaching for his gun and
sees what seems to be a dapper shadow
standing right behind him a tall man
with a long black coat and a wide
brimmed hat no face just darkness itself
under the shade of the brim the stranger
places a calm hand on his shoulder and
suddenly a sense of trust like he hasn't
felt in years just sets in somehow deep
in his marrow he knows that this man is
here to help rest assured sergeant
everything is under control now for i
the specter have arrived to save the day
how many criminals are inside the
sergeant murmurs ten and all the spectre
nods worry not sergeant nobody will die
today and with that like the ghost that
is his very namesake the spectre is gone
inside the bank the leader of the
robbers checks his watch two minutes and
still no word from the cops outside he's
starting to lose his patience a few
unfortunate bank tellers and customers
crouch around him their hands behind
their heads five of his men are out here
with him armed in keeping the situation
under control the other four have
cracked the security on the vault and
they're hauling out money by the bag
full and still silence from the cops he
sneers and the thought crosses his mind
that perhaps if he takes out a hostage
or two now the mooks out there might
actually take his threat seriously that
thought amuses him yeah that'll show him
he'll finally know who they're dealing
with here the leader shoulders his
assault rifle and draws a bead on the
hostages sitting closest to him even as
men are shocked by the suddenness of it
all but they know better than to
second-guess their boss at a time like
this he was always a little
trigger-happy the hostage and older
gentleman who'd only come into the bank
to check his balance because he hadn't
figured out how to do it online just yet
seize the gun and winces he survived nam
and this was how he was going to go
gunned down on a wednesday afternoon by
some creep for chump change what a world
the leader's finger curls around the
trigger but before he can complete a
squeeze an expertly aimed fist collides
with the back of his head knocking him
unconscious in a single strike the
leader collapses his rifle sliding
across the ground the spectre stands
where he stood straightening his coat
and blowing dandruff off of his knuckles
are you fellas ready to dance he growls
he glides through them moving with the
grace of a prima ballerina and hitting
with the force of a freight train the
goons are down before any of them can
fire a single shot with the help of some
quick thinking bank tellers the spectre
closes the vault door from the outside
trapping the remaining four robbers
inside textbook crime fighting once more
the bank customers and employees weeping
with joy and relief thank the specter
for saving their lives he shakes his
hand and assures them it was nothing
just doing what he could as any
concerned citizen should he would have
left after that were it not for one
little problem the nypd has a number of
employees at different levels of their
sprawling structure that are actually
deeply embedded undercover agents of the
scp foundation and this isn't a comic
book there's a word for when a
mysterious man made from darkness
appears from nowhere and effortlessly
takes down 10 heavily armed highly
trained combatants by himself and that
word was anomalous knowing what this
mysterious combatant was capable of the
foundation sends some of their best
mobile task force operatives to
apprehend him under the guise of just
being standard swat team members sent in
to get the situation back under control
in the aftermath of the robbery however
much to their extreme surprise the
spectre puts up absolutely no resistance
to them he understands that the men here
to apprehend him are servants of law and
order and would not defy their will but
he pleads with them to reconsider you
don't understand sirs you're making a
huge mistake he says distraught i'm here
to help i'm the specter defender of the
innocent scourge of the evildoer you
can't lock me away you can't the people
need me
as tragic as it is to see a genuinely
benevolent anomaly beg for his freedom
the mobile task force's hearts have long
since hardened to this kind of thing he
wouldn't be the first sapient humanoid
anomaly to speedrun all seven stages of
grief on their knees in front of them
and he probably wouldn't be the last
foundation protocol is to tag and bag
either way even if they just use their
anomalous abilities to thwart a bank
robbery the spectre is hauled back to
the nearest foundation containment site
and held in a holding cell while
researchers prepare to conduct initial
tests and questioning everything seems
so run-of-the-mill little do they notice
something extremely strange is starting
to happen to new york city beyond the
containment chamber's walls they're
about to learn the true devastating
consequences of keeping a pure force of
good like the spectre locked up like a
switch has been flipped nearby police
suddenly become oddly listless instead
of working they just chat with each
other and random citizens about the
weather some watch scp explained on
their phone while active robberies are
happening a man is mugged right in front
of a squad car and the cop inside just
listens to his van halen cds at max
volume in actual precincts the on duty
cops start to wonder why on earth
they're actually here in this building
all together listening to phone calls
from weirdly panicked people and typing
up reports on
stuff it all just seems oddly confusing
they decide to go outside and watch
clouds or go home and play video games
it doesn't make any sense that they're
just standing around in here doing
nothing for no reason across the city
strange incidents start to occur people
who so much as knock into each other
while walking on the crowded new york
streets begin to brawl with one another
on the ground while nobody around them
even really acknowledges that they're
doing it let alone tries to break them
up nearby cars crash at the intersection
and rather than getting out to exchange
insurance information the rate drivers
draw guns and start to duel like bit
characters in an old cowboy movie nobody
really seems to mind as if noticing a
change in the wind organized crime
rackets decide that secrecy isn't the
way to go anymore mob enforcers rob
stores and shake down random people in
the streets taking wallets watches
phones and jewelry criminals break into
people's homes and start ransacking the
place stealing everything from flat
screen tvs to priceless family heirlooms
while their owners sit on the couch
seemingly unable to even comprehend that
something is going wrong here but
everything is still about to get a whole
lot worse the city breaks into riots and
looting people battling in the streets
news helicopters circle above reporting
the chaos unfolding below them but they
do so with an odd kind of detached calm
not really comprehending the full scope
of what's happening or why just that a
whole lot more is on fire now than it
was before how strange
this is the moment when the scp
foundation realizes the meaning of the
specters pleading he really was being
entirely unselfish because you see the
spectre isn't just an extremely devoted
crime fighter he's the very
personification of the concept of
fighting crime he can't ever be locked
up or contained because if you do then
the very concept of resisting crime
fades from the human consciousness order
ceases to be and chaos reigns that's why
the spectre also known as scp-4494
is classified as archon meaning that he
can't be contained because the danger of
containing him would be far greater than
the danger of letting him roam around
and do his thing unhindered he maintains
an amicable relationship with the scp
foundation after everything that
happened willing to swoop in and help
their agents when they're in a bind and
need a little hand from a true hero and
when he's not fighting crime he relaxes
in the spectre cave by watching tv and
playing video games no we're not making
that up unsurprisingly his favorite
video games are the ones where you get
to play as superheroes though he will
occasionally indulge in some grand theft
auto 5. just don't expect him to break
any traffic laws while he's playing
thank you very much so if ever you feel
afraid or if the dark forces that are
all too human in this world are
marshalling against you know this you
don't fight alone there's a man in the
shadows ready to come to your aid he's a
warrior for justice he's a defender of
the innocent but most of all he is
the spectre
now go check out
scp-999 tickle monster versus the most
evil scps and scp-999 and the most
wholesome scps for more anomalies that
really just want to make the world a
better place